is an absolute legend and he's been
dubbed internationally as being one of
the greatest drummers of all time and
he's obviously most known for performing
with the rolling stones which has become
the epitome of rock and roll here in the
uk as well as internationally and he has
died at the age of 18 and performed
right up until the age of 78 and he
famously described his life with the
rolling stones as five years of playing
and 20 years of hanging around and his
last concept with the group took place
in miami in
2019 and he was on stage for more than
50 years which is an awfully long time
earlier this year we did have to
withdraw from a post-pandemic tour a
citing that he needed to recover from an
unspecified but successful recent
medical procedure and so it's not known
what happened with that but
unfortunately in a statement today it
has been announced that he died so a
statement from his london publicist
bernard dougherty to pa news said that
it is with immense sadness that we
announced the death of our beloved
charlie watts he passed away peacefully
in a london hospital early today
surrounded by his family charlie was a
cherished husband father and grandfather
and also as a member of the rolling
stones one of the greatest drummers of
his generation they added that we will
kindly request that the privacy of his
family and his
members and close friends is respected
at this very difficult time
now watts is survived by his wife and
his daughter and i'm guessing that much
more of those comments and memories
about charlie watts will be coming
through later today